[Your Tuberculosis Association presents]
["You Can Help"]
[Narrator:] One of the dread four horsemen
of the apocalypse is pestilence, the plagues
that have scourged mankind since earliest
times. Of these, none has claimed more lives
than the white plague, tuberculosis.
Some of the greatest names in medicine have
waged the war against TB since Hippocrates
first defined its symptoms five hundred years
before the time of Christ.
But it was a little more than a hundred years
ago that the chance observation of children
listening to the magnified sounds of tapping
on a hollow log gave Laennec, a young French
doctor, the inspiration for the stethoscope.
Later in the 19th century, Villemin proved
that TB was a contagious disease. Then Louis
Pasteur discovered that germs were the cause
of contagious disease.
The German scientist Koch was the first to
find the TB germ, the tubercule bacillus.
But not until Roentgen discovered x-ray could
the actual destruction caused by the germ
be seen inside the living body.
Modern sanatorium treatment in this country
began in the Adirondacks, when Trudeau found
that rest, fresh air and good food helped
him to recover from the supposedly incurable
TB.
Nineteen-hundred, and with the new century
came a new idea; to fight TB with knowledge.
To teach people about TB so that it can be
found early when chances for recovery are
best.
With this in mind, a group of scientists,
physicians, and other public-spirited citizens
founded what is now the National Tuberculosis
Association.
From these beginnings came the local TB association
in your community, formed by your neighbors
in the interest of better public health.
Here's how it works; the people elect a board
of directors, representing a cross-section
of the community, businessmen and housewives,
churchmen, doctors, educators, newspaper men,
industrialists, and legislators.
The board employs an executive secretary;
together they plan a program for tuberculosis
control. The secretary needs a staff of trained
technical workers to mobilize the army of
volunteers so necessary for community action
against TB.
[Fact Finding]
A program begins with fact-finding. The secretary
must know how many deaths were caused by TB
during the past year. Are there enough doctors,
nurses, social workers, sanatorium beds, clinics,
and hospitals?
Are there special groups in the community
with a higher incidence of TB? For his information,
the secretary consults agencies like these.
[Image of buildings with signs outside, "Board
of Education, Medical Society, Hospitals,
Health Dept., Dept. Public Welfare, Chambers
of Commerce."]
From them he can fill in his picture of the
community, learn its weak points, know how
to build a most effective program.
Of primary importance to such a program is
health education, carefully planned with the
help of other community organizations. For
education must be more than merely telling
a story. It was must influence behavior, form
habits of thought and action.
Additional persons must be reached through
those already educated. Finally, it must create
a demand for more education, for which leadership
has been developed.
Thus the association plans its educational
program for the use of such groups as teachers
and school administrators, speakers, churchmen,
and those being trained for professional careers:
doctors, nurses, and social workers.
The association can reach all groups because
its board of directors is drawn from all aspects
of community life. Largely an educational
job is the phase of the association's work
known as Case Finding.
Control of TB depends on finding the people
who have it before there are symptoms, before
the victims themselves are aware of it. Unknown
cases are often found by the family physician
in the course of physical examinations and
among young people by tuberculin testing in
the schools.
If people are made aware of the value of periodic
chest x-rays, the TB discovered will usually
be in the early stage. If, however, TB is
not looked for until the patient displays symptoms
of the disease, the cases found are apt to
be in the far advanced state when cure is
uncertain and costly.
The association may be called upon to furnish
x-ray equipment, x-ray film, or technical
and clerical services until such time as the
health department can take over the responsibilities.
Since TB control depends on finding unknown
and unsuspected cases; a program to wipe out
the disease must strive to x-ray every adult
in the community.
To do this, the health department and the
tuberculosis association organize local committees
made up of public-spirited volunteers. With
their help and with the impetus given the
drive by industry, church, school, and welfare
groups, complete coverage of the community
is assured.
[Treatment]
Those individuals whose x-ray indicates TB
are re-examined by the private physician and
the health department. The local association
may help by supplying public health nursing,
social service, or other professional aides
as demonstration to the community to show,
for example, the need for adequate following
up of a case.
Follow-up work includes the medical examination
and x-ray of contacts, the family, and close
associates of the person found to have TB.
When the person with TB is receiving treatment,
the association works with the sanatorium
staff to give him and his family the facts
they need to know about TB. The patient must
be prepared for instance, for a long period
of bed treatment; perhaps training for a new
job will be necessary.
For early in his sanatorium stay, the association
and other agencies are beginning to plan for
his eventual convalescence and re-employment.
Once discharged from the sanatorium, he can
look to his family physician as well as his
TB association and health department for advice
on his job, his recreation, and the facilities
available for physical checkups.
If the facilities for helping discharged patients
and their families do not exist, the association
must try to influence the proper agencies
to appropriate funds to cover the needs.
[Public Information]
Among the greatest influencing factors open
to the TB association are the channels of
public information: the press, from the large
dailies to the hand-printed school newspapers,
Radio and television. A year-round public
information campaign, invaluable as an aid
to an educational program, also serves to
tell you how your money is being spent, what
is being done for the public health in your
community.
[Seal Sale] The entire program of the tuberculosis association is financed by the sale of Christmas Seals
primarily through the mail or by volunteers selling TB seals and health bonds.
Of the money collected in the community, 95
percent remains in the community and state
where it was raised, thus the people who contributed
can see the visible results of service within
their community.
The remaining five percent goes to the National
Association, which, like the state association,
exists as a service organization for the local,
channeling information, producing materials,
and giving consultation.
These three -- the national, state, and local
associations -- work together to further TB
control on their respective levels. In some
instances, they can extend their work to other
health needs.
They also work together in the large program
of research, from which it is hoped will eventually
come the cure for the disease. Meanwhile,
tuberculosis, once the cause of more deaths
than any other single disease, is being defeated
in the United States with the weapons now
available.
The goal of your tuberculosis association
is to stamp out TB forever in your community.
You can help.
[ Music ]
[The End, Produced for the National Tuberculosis
Association by the Paul J. Fennell Co.]